なんかあの歩くバールのように扱われているロバがなんとなく愛おしく感じてきたんですけど
うん ちょっとの方を聞き上げというかなか人間の生活にすごく近いところにいるような感じが
うるさいでしょうねとかねうん 本格が何がによってもん
どうやってなき声あるんですか?うん アウトリスメンでよなぁ
まあそうかもしれないね まあ音量だから ああそうかー
いやあそうさん 教師の状態にうまんのおくときは
本当
話してると乗りたくなっていくでしょうね きっとね
うん できるとも
うん
「体が覚えてくるでしょうね」
「体が覚えてるでしょうね」
「そうね。もう乗った途端に分かってしまうみたいですよね」
「あの馬の背中に乗っちゃえばもう大丈夫でしょうね。車が高いから」
「乗っちゃえばもう全然、どこでもいける感じでしょうね」
「乗るのは一人で乗れるの?」
「一人で乗れるの?」
「うん。あのー、台があることもあるわよね」
「台を用意しました」
「台ですよね。今は下から乗るのは大変だけども」
「下から乗るのは初めは覚えなきゃいけないですよね」
「あぶみの蔵を持って」
「でも安子さん、私は初めて見たフリシマス」
「うん。本当にそう」
「どんなサイストインプレッションですか?」
「違う人みたい?」
「しっこいコマンドがある」
「とても自信である」
「うん。そう。乗る。そう。乗る。」
「馬に乗る自信?」
「自信。自信しながら馬に乗っていることが」
「乗っていることが」
「そうね。でも初めての馬だったら自信、自信なんてないですよ。全然」
「もう知ってる馬だったらね」
「お互いに知ってれば」
「とても、私よりいい」
「持ってたんでしょ?自分の馬を」
「今乗ってないのよ。だから」
「今も持ってますね。今を」